si je me suis engagé en politique c'est
parce que je crois en la force de la
vérité depuis cinq ans je n'ai vu que
des mensonges il restera du quinquennat
d'evel macron sept présidents cette
image d'un président au teint solitaire
et bien sûr arrogant nous avons avec
valérie celle qui a le projet le plus
solide qui soit nous avons avec valérie
celtia autour d'elle l'équipe la plus
solide qui soit nous sommes là avec
valérie pécresse
vous êtes là nous disons que nous
voulons une europe qui renforce les
nations et non une europe qui se
renforce en fragilisant les états qui la
composent oui mes amis la france aspire
à reconstruire elle aspire à retrouver
les valeurs qui sont les siennes et nous
avons besoin d'un sursaut d'un sursaut
qui la hisse au niveau de son glorieux
héritage il existe le choix du courage
le choix de l'honnêteté le choix de la
détermination et ce choix et bien mes
amis vous le savez il a un visage il
annoncé valérie pécresse à nous d'être
combatif à ses côtés à nous de nous
battre de toutes nos forces l'essentiel
c'est qu'elle france voulons-nous demain
avec moi le travail paiera il payera
plus que l'assistanat c'est une question
de dignité nous le devons à nous sous
vrillé à nous employer à la france des
premières lignes aux classes moyennes
qui travaillent dur on peut emmener très
loin les français en aimant éperdument
la france car la france ça n'est pas
seulement une oeuvre de l'esprit c'est
un élan du coeur qui appelle tous les
français à qui emmanuel macron infligé
son mépris à nous rejoindre
j'appelle les courageux de première
ligne qualifié de dernier de cordée le
10 avril prochain j'appelle les français
à être des citoyens libres je les
appelle à la révolte contre des
scénarios écrits d'avancé
invite la france celle qui s'ac jour se
retrouve c'est moche celle qui appelle
la république à la rescousse celle qui
veut ordre et justice et je leur dis
rejoignez nous rejoignez moi
[Applaudissements]